I just had a conversation right now with
somebody very powerful
person in office politically we had a
two-hour lunch together and we were
talking about one of the candidates how
big of a role the spouse plays in this
one candidate and how this candidate
made multiple bad decisions that ruined
their political career because they
listened to the wrong person so you know
there's also listening to the wrong Mom
the wrong dad the wrong husband the
wrong wife the wrong sibling so no two
situations are the same you have to be
very very
aware intuitive patient strategic
forgiving but if the vision is Big you
can't be winged in that part especially
with family because family is going to
use guilt and family is going to use you
know well it's not fair you should do
this for your sister you should do that
for your brother you should do that I'm
your dad I'm your mom I'm your this I'm
your dad and I have I have a lot of
respect for that but sometimes that
prevents the person from going and doing
something